the daily average of covid
hospitalizations
is up back to 25 000 americans
covid related deaths standing at roughly
daily down slightly though from june
states are seeing some of the highest
increases in coveted cases
florida alabama maine massachusetts and
new york
los angeles county already mandating
mask wearing indoors regardless of
vaccination status
las vegas also recommending them again
among other areas
and today on capitol hill cdc director
rochelle
wielinski addressed the spike in cases
and urged those who have not yet
been vaccinated to do so
in areas where vaccine coverage is low
cases and hospitalizations are starting
to climb again
the message from cdc remains clear the
best way to prevent the spread of covet
19 variants is to prevent the spread of
disease
and vaccination is the most powerful
tool we have
the overwhelming majority of deaths from
covet 19 are now
occurring in unvaccinated people now the
american academy of pediatrics is
recommending
all children ages 3 and up wear masks in
schools this fall regardless of
vaccination status
dr anthony fauci says he agrees
i think that the american academy of
pediatrics you know they're a thoughtful
group
they analyze the situation and if they
feel that that's the way to go i think
that's reasonable thing to do
senator ted cruz republican from the
great state of texas
is in focus now and he's already shaking
his head so let's just get your top line
thoughts
you know at some point fauci became a
saturday night live caricature enough
already with the mandates listen covid
is a serious disease we've treated it
seriously
vaccines are important i've been
vaccinated heidi's been vaccinated my
parents have been vaccinated her parents
have been vaccinated
i think it's a good thing to get
vaccinated but but
we're seeing big government status
who are wanting to mandate vaccinations
who are wanting shutdowns again
who are wanting mass mandates again
shutdowns were a colossal
failure they destroyed lives they
destroyed businesses
and and these masked mandates don't make
any sense and you know fauci has
at this point now embraced every
position
under the sun on just about every issue
last year
in his emails and publicly was saying
masks don't do anything now he's saying
mask everybody you're seeing people
talking about even people who've been
vaccinated
should wear masks it doesn't make any
sense we need to use
common sense and and common sense does
not entail
having three-year-olds wearing masks as
we are vaccinating
a very significant percentage of our
population
well senator uh you know the way that
you just laid that out
it made me think of something that i
hadn't thought of before and and it's
almost like
fauci and and part of that group that
that he calls you know the the brightest
among those scientists who were studying
this and well-intentioned
um which is all true um they're they're
looking at this and they're saying well
let's protect everybody who hasn't been
vaccinated
our job was to protect everybody who had
co-morbidities over the age of like 75
and as you said we we've done everything
we can do with the best weapon
those people have made their decision
now many of them who are not immune
compromised
about what they're going to do with
vaccinations which is why you made your
decision to go get one as well as heidi
so on and so forth last word on that
but listen people you need to exercise
common sense i believe in individual
responsibility and
and and freedom uh and so certainly if
someone is elderly if they have health
issues i think it makes a lot of sense
to get vaccinated
um you know one of the next
battlegrounds is going to be vaccinating
kids listen we have not vaccinated our
girls who are 10 and 13
because the the rate of serious illness
for children from covet is is so low
uh that that in our judgment it didn't
make sense as a cost-benefit analysis
but every family ought to make that
judgment
based on your family members and love
members i'll tell you what doesn't make
sense harris
the biden administration is talking
about wanting to end
title 42. title 42 is the statute that
has allowed
uh adults to be illegal immigrants to be
excluded during a pandemic and they're
wanting to release now
essentially everybody and and given that
we've been seeing consistently high
rates of covet infection from illegal
immigrants
the biden administration is contributing
to the spread of this virus
by releasing illegal immigrants against
the law into our communities and it's
driving up the rates of covid
particularly in in south texas along the
border that seems like
indisputable facts i mean i i don't know
that you're going to get a debate on
that one because all you have to do is
count
right and we know our capacity of
testing right now we
we can barely process them at the border
yesterday in del rio texas there were
300 people flooding in
from from the river i mean we saw those
pictures live you bring up
such an important point i i have to move
on though because i want us to cover
some other things
a lot of backlash today senator after
the white house
admitted to flagging social media posts
it deems
misinformation as well as asking
facebook data to help police
those posts press secretary jin saki
dodged a question on the specific
post and it wanted facebook to remove
and
if that will be made public watch
first of all we've not asked facebook to
block
any individual posts the way this works
is that
there are trending there are trends that
are out there on social media platforms
you're aware of them it's up to social
media platforms to determine
uh what their application is of their
own
rules and regulations and so we just
certainly raise
where we have concerns about information
that's inaccurate
i'll add this quicken president biden
walked back those original claims that
he had that facebook is killing people
with misinformation
facebook isn't killing people these 12
people are out there
giving misinformation anyone listening
to it is getting hurt by it
it's killing people it's bad information
my hope is that facebook instead of
taking it personally that somehow i'm
saying facebook is killing people
that they would do something about the
misinformation they owe
outrageous misinformation about the
vaccine
so he went back to blaming 12 people we
don't know who they are
are they keeping lists of americans that
they think are wrong or don't agree with
lots of questions critics ripping
biden's total 180 on the issue
one tweeted this not the
administration's finest hour another
you shouldn't take me calling you a
murderer personally
and another asks so was the previous
statement misinformation
senator cruz listen the biden
administration
believes in power they want to have the
power to silence you they want to have
the power to silence any criticism i
gotta admit for a politician
if you could have all your critics
simply disappear and unable to criticize
you
that might be pretty nice it's contrary
to the constitution it's contrary to the
first amendment
it's contrary to a free democracy but
but the byte administration is getting
big
tech to be the arm in silencing critics
and by the way what they call
misinformation
very conveniently always benefits
democrats always benefits joe biden
they've been wrong over and over and
over again so they got big tech for
example
to silence to disappear to block the new
york post
for the story on hunter biden's laptop
why because it was politically damaging
to joe biden we now know that story was
true but they called it misinformation
they also got big tech to block anyone
suggesting that the wuhan virus
actually came from the chinese
government labs in wuhan it now
i think the preponderance of the
evidence suggests that the virus escaped
from a chinese government lab
and yet big tech made that disappear
and one of the striking things so it's
interesting watching the biden white
house try to
backstep a little bit from from their
statements last week
but what they have inadvertently done is
they have strengthened
president donald trump's lawsuit against
big tech against facebook and twitter
and google
because look what president trump argues
in the lawsuit is that they are
violating the first amendment by
censoring americans
the biggest argument they have in their
defense is their private companies not
the government
and and the first amendment only applies
to the government well
there's an exception to that the supreme
court has long recognized
which is the government can't use a
private company
to carry out a government policy and
here this is what they're doing here the
biden white house
is asking the big tech monopolists
please
silence block disappear any views
we disagree with and and i think that's
blatantly illegal it's also an abuse of
power that
that is really contrary to to the
principles
that our country was built on well and
we know that that's what's going no
matter what they say from the lectern
now because they originally told us that
they get together regularly
yeah with these big tech corporations to
talk about the misinformation and
facebook posts
and by the way yeah i don't know if we
know this and we'll move on i'll just
ask
this rhetorically what happens if you
get on one of those lists
because i was posting on my twitter just
little me i don't matter
but you know i'm not a billion facebook
users obviously
questions about the wuhan lab league a
year ago stickered problematic
or problematic whatever what happens if
you get on their list
senator cruz how do you get off that
list and what does it mean when they go
after those 12 people
if we can't even identify them as a
journalist i don't know how you hold
them accountable if something goes wrong
in their processing well they don't want
to be held accountable and
and big tech is asserting the power over
all of journalism if they could they'd
block all of fox news they haven't gone
that far yet but that's where they want
to go
we've seen that they're willing to throw
donald trump off of social media and
claim
completely unaccountable arbitrary power
if they can do that to him
they can do that to anybody and it is
amazing
the so-called journalists at cnn abc cbs
the new york times the washington post
who just
meekly go along with a handful of
silicon valley
billionaires the modern oligarchs like
the russian oligarchs
we have the silicon valley oligarchs and
the media is perfectly happy to have
these billionaires
determine who gets to speak who doesn't
and what you get to say
it is the single biggest threat to free
speech in america it's the
single biggest threat to democracy in
america i think we need to break up
these big tech companies
i think we need to stop them from
censoring american citizens they
are out of control all right let's get
to this an
aid for speaker pelosi and speaker
both have tested positive for covid
after attending the same
reception last week pelosi staffer
that one helped usher a group of texas
house democrats around the capitol last
week and yet
another one of those runaway texas house
democrats
has tested positive for covid bringing
the total now to six
more than 10 percent of that group that
fled to d.c to protest
a republican state election reform bill
that's a growing number really rapidly
last night
40 of those democrats held a virtual
town hall to push for a federal voting
law
and again painted themselves as heroes
let's watch
we're sacrificing a lot more than just
time away from our families
but all that sacrifice is worth it
it's worth it to protect texans it's
worth it to fight
for the american dream it's worth it to
make sure that we have a future
to leave to our children a washington
examiner op-ed
says texas democrats cannot do anything
right here's the quote
to recap texas democrats lost yet
another election in 2020.
they fled their own state to prevent the
majority from passing a benign piece of
legislation
they charted a flight that they took
mask list
to washington then five now six
tested positive for the virus and also
exposed
the vice president senator cruz this is
your home state of texas you have seen
what i know with my relatives in texas
we don't do we don't cut and run
that's what i've heard some republicans
accuse them of what is the next phase
that they're in now
well listen karma is a remarkable thing
and and and this this episode really
embodies i think
all that's wrong with the modern
democratic party number one
they're willing to mandate rules for for
all americans that they ignore that they
flaunt themselves so you have democrats
that are eager to see mass mandates on
everybody who've been champions of
lockdowns and of course
when they get on their flight they all
take their masks off and end up a bunch
of them
getting coveted but but secondly this is
a political stunt
you know we're seeing these these texas
house democrats that are holding
themselves up as these
heroic civil rights warriors you know
they've likened it to the edmund pettus
bridge well i guess that's that's that's
right if people on the edmund pettus
bridge who were standing up to the dogs
and the beatings and the clubs
were actually on a private jet with
miller light sitting back
in luxury i mean this is it's a silly
political stunt
the law that they're protesting is a
common sense election integrity law
they claim it's voter suppression it's
things like signature verification on
absentee
votes it's things like cameras and
counting rooms so that you actually
have accountability but here's the good
news harris that this stunt's going to
fail
they're going to run around and and
spend a lot of time on a lot of tv
networks getting a bunch of attention
and then they're going to come back to
texas and when they come back to texas
the governor has rightly said he's going
to call another special session another
special session
when they come back the texas
constitution is clear they can be
arrested
and if they refuse to come and do their
jobs they will be arrested and
physically taken to the floor of the
house and the legislature is going to do
its job it's going to pass this
legislation
and and and this this political stunt is
not going to succeed yeah the
the attorney general uh of the state of
texas your home
ken paxton told me last week that
absolutely they have the right to do it
and absolutely they will do it if it's
necessary he said the goal isn't to take
them to
to jail he said taxpayers are paying
them to go to work
so he's just trying to get him as you
say senator back to the capitol real
quick last thought
you know a bit of history in 2003 i was
the solicitor general of texas and texas
democrats did that then as well they
fled the state
to try to stop the state from doing
redistricting and one of the first
questions i got as solicitor general
was this question can you arrest fleeing
legislature
laters who are trying to stop the
legislature from meeting i researched
the question
the texas constitution explicitly
authorizes
using force to compel the attendants
that language is copied word for word
from the u.s
constitution and there's hundreds of
years of precedent of arresting fleeing
legislators
the power to literally put them in in
handcuffs and leg irons if necessary
you know in the u.s senate senator bob
packwood was carried onto the senate
floor
feet first and and so the answer is
and and it's not a rest to go to jail
it's not to go to presidency it is to
make them physically present on the
floor so that they don't get to stop the
operation of government and the rule of
law and that that's going to be the end
of this
on a lot of things outside of election
bills i mean you know i know that you
all are trying to revisit the grid
issues that you
that you had problems with in the winter
that froze and you had all sorts of
trouble for citizens there
i mean there are a lot of things to get
to uh right away senator ted cruz always
great to have you in the faulkner focus
thank you so very much
appreciate it hi i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now